But but why are you leaving you? I'm a free agent now
Will you be back
Yes
One way or another
Your stash brother steven will look after you now, you'll be in good hands
??, she'll be right?
well, I must be going now time for me to test the Market [yah]
yah yah fare be well brothers ?? you mate
Fare well Kevin, now I do what I want
I Know you and russ had your issues, but I can assure you there will be no such chemistry problems here
Well, that's nice to hear
Plus You'll have the services of the premiere point guard in the realm
wait uh so better than steph curry well certainly top three well there's Russell and Chris Paul
Top three point guard in the East is what I meant okay?
Ok well than there's Kyrie Irving's [off] Kyries Gotta be number one and then Kyle lowry
He's pretty good these days and Isaiah Thomas [shut up Bradley]. Do you want him to play here or not?
I'm just being honest oh you want honestly I'd be top three easy my max contract shooting guard wasn't always injured
oh, so sorry, John I put my body on the line for this team
Oh I'm Bradley I'm made of cloth
Will you to twits shut up
As I was saying the chemistry here definitely top five in the in east
so
What's that? What's that over there? whats that box
soul box
I'm sorry you said soul box soul box soul box so like a box
For souls when you sign the spurs your soul and your personality are put into the box
Right so do I get it back
indubitably
[haha]
So what are your thoughts on tanken'?
Oh, it's true if you were to join us. You'd be endlessly
Ridiculed your old teammates will despise you and the fans in Oklahoma will cook their stew on the flames of your burning jersey
People will call you a traitor a coward and some may say you've destroyed the entire balance of the realm
But on the other hand if you were to join us, we would be
So good
Cleveland, this is for you
But we will win not just one championship
Not two, Lebron. I'm sorry yeah, you might want to read this can this wait not three
It's concerned some changes next year if this is about Deli going to the Bucks. I think we'll live
not four
but
But what one is fine some people never get championships and and we should be happy with this one